putting on Bruce Springsteen
it's great maybe Johnny Cash Hurt maybe
maybe that one I ain't knocking Bruce
Springsteen like I have a lot of great
Bruce Springsteen memories truly his
music's fantastic yeah yeah not
meditating on mortality to Bruce
Springsteen well you know what I'm just
trying to do an audio soundtrack in my
head
I guess we can each have our own audios
on track
[Music]
I'm on fire it's so good yeah it's a
good thing a night uh uh the sheet
soaking wet and the freight train
running through the middle of my head
and only you can cool my desire and he's
thinking about someone else's girl yeah
what a [ __ ] nightmare yeah Bruce
Springsteen's laying in bed with a
freight train running through his head
thinking about banging your wife and
you're out of town oh my god oh you're
taking the other guy's perspective like
holy [ __ ] this guy's gonna get my wife
it's Bruce but yeah
both perspectives I'm sure Bruce
Springsteen thought it was love when
he's sweating in bed waiting to go to
somebody's house and she does too you
what does that marry if he's gonna break
up that marriage that marriage wasn't
strong enough right I mean
that relationship I mean that's the way
of love
could survive Bruce Springsteen sweaty
Bruce Springsteen
uh well maybe one that's based on
financial
um uh sort of financial Dynamics versus
like love and sweaty Bruce Springsteen
like
um like romantic connections because in
that there's like a
there's a music video of that where he's
like a mechanic I think
yeah so he's like the poor mechanic who
is uh
Who falls in love with this girl and
this is that magic
um I've seen that magic you connect with
people like uh I'll see somebody I think
Jack Kerouac has that where he meets uh
this Mexican girl uh on a bus and like
he talks about that heartbreak you feel
when you realize this person you just
fell in love with in a split second is
heading somewhere else in this two big
world yeah uh but then he actually
realizes in uh spoiler alert for on the
road that they're actually heading the
same way and he now builds up the
courage to talk to her and they kind of
fall in love for a few days yeah and
then realize eventually realizes that
she may not be the perfect person for
him and all the jealousy that comes out
it's like why is this beautiful girl
talking to me at all and then she's
probably some kind of I mean and that's
you know it's not very politically
correct but he basically thinks that
she's a prostitute and he uh talks to
her about like who's your pimp and all
that kind of stuff he had attacks her
and all that all that kind of way when
she's just an innocent
right she has you know she has a past of
that kind but she's an innocent person
and he connected and they fell in love
with each other her gentleness his
worldliness all that kind of stuff
um but that sometimes it doesn't work
out that way and there's that heartbreak
when you see you realize
um
you're never going to be able to have
that and that's Bruce Springsteen saw
that this is a married woman I'm never
going to be able to have that but I want
that and that's the Heartbreak I gotta
say I just assumed they were [ __ ]
like I didn't right after the song like
the song doesn't get to uh little girl
is your daddy home did he go away and
leave you all alone you know he's like
he knows she's at home alone
yeah but it never
materializes he's he's he's
longing it's a it's a man who's not with
the the thing he craves for so he's
longing for he's talking about the long
game right not with the having hey if
anybody in the CIA is watching this can
you look into Bruce Springsteen's file
and let us know if he actually banged
the person yeah
between the song we want facts